[MUSIC PLAYING]
SABA ZAIDI: My
husband and I have
been in a somewhat long-distance
relationship for a few years
now.
We talk on the phone
and message a lot.
But perhaps what's
most enjoyable
for me is when I visit him.
I leave little notes
all over his apartment.
And sometimes when
I'm home alone,
he'll start changing the
color of the smart lights
in my living room to let me
know that he's thinking of me.
Our human conversations take
a lot of different forms.
We don't just talk verbally.
Depending on where we are
and what we're trying to say,
we might write, hold
hands, or even change
color of smart lights.
It's these human
conversations that
have inspired us to create
conversations with technology.
It's no surprise then
that we're starting
to incorporate more modalities
into our digital interactions
as well.
But with this increased number
of devices and complexity
of interactions, it might
feel overwhelming to design
for the Google Assistant.
If you look at the
Google Assistant today,
I can talk to it not
just through the speaker
in my living room, but
also through my car
or my headphones.
I can tap on my
phone or my watch.
But how do we design
for an increased number
of complexity of devices?
I'm Saba Zaidi, and I'm
an interaction designer
on the Google Assistant team.
I'll be talking about how
you can design actions
across surfaces and give you
some frameworks and some tips.
ULAS KIRAZCI: And hi, I'm Ulas.
I'm an engineer on
Actions on Google.
And later on, I'm
going to tell you
how to build an action
using the design
principle Saba will talk about.
SABA ZAIDI: OK.
So before we can get
started to understand
how to design actions
across surfaces,
we need to get a
better understanding
of what those experiences
can look like.
Let's start with a journey
through a user's day.
You wake up in the morning
to the sound of an alarm
ringing on your Google Home.
Without even getting out
your blanket, you can say,
hey, Google, stop.
You get up, get ready.
And as you're about
to head out, you
want to make sure you
don't need an umbrella.
So you turn to the smart
display in your hallway
and you ask, hey, Google,
what's the weather today?
You're able to hear a
summary, and also at a glance
see the hourly forecast.
As you're walking to your
car, you take out your phone
and tap on it to ask the
Google Assistant to order
your favorite from Starbucks.
It's able to connect
you to Starbucks,
where you can quickly
place your order.
As you're driving, you want to
listen to your favorite podcast
or the news.
And you can ask Google Assistant
for help in a hands-free way.
And it can connect you, for
example, to NPR News update.
You go about your day.
And when you come
back home, it's
time to make dinner
for your family.
You turn to the smart
display in your kitchen
and you ask, for example,
Tasty for help with a recipe,
like in this case, pizza bombs.
Tasty comes back, and
you can hear and see
on the screen
step-by-step instructions
and the ingredients.
After dinner, it's time
to unwind with your family
in the living room.
You decide to play a
Buzzfeed personality quiz.
And it's a great
way for your family
to get together around a shared
device and have some fun.
And then you head to bed.
You say, hey,
Google, good night.
It's able to start your
custom bedtime routine, which
includes, for example,
setting your alarms
or telling you about
your day tomorrow.
So as you can see, users
were able to interact
with the Google Assistant
similar to human interactions
in that there were a lot of
different ways and contexts.
And although there were a
lot of different devices,
there are some
overarching principles.
So let's take a look at them.
First, the experience
was familiar.
Whether it was morning,
evening, or commute,
users can access their favorite
Google Assistant actions
whenever, wherever
they need them.
The Assistant was available
in different contexts.
You saw it being used
on the go and at home,
up close and from
a distance, and
in shared and private settings.
So as you're thinking
about your actions,
think about all the different
contexts it may be used in.
And lastly, different
devices lend themselves
to different modes
of interaction.
Some are voice only,
some are visual,
and some were a mix of both.
And we'll talk a bit more about
the strengths and weaknesses
of each of these
modalities in a bit.
First, let's take a deeper look
at a couple of those devices
and see how these
principles apply.
You've already heard
about smart displays now.
They were announced
earlier this year.
And even though
it's a new device,
users can expect it
to feel familiar.
It's essentially like a
Google Home with a screen.
It's designed to be used
at home from a distance
and as a shared device.
And as you can see in this
inspiration action example,
even though there's
a screen, users still
interact with the
device through voice.
They don't have to tap through
complex app navigation.
Instead, the
visuals are designed
to be seen at a distance.
And of course, the user
can walk up to the screen
and touch it if they want.
Next, let's take a
quick look at phones.
One thing to note
here is that we're
making phones more
visually assistive as well,
similar to smart displays,
allowing for a greater
focus on the content.
These devices, as you know, are
great for use cases, on the go,
up close, and in a
private environment.
And users can interact with the
Google Assistant on the phone
through both voice and visuals.
So hopefully that gave
you a better sense
of what the experiences
on Google Assistant
look like across devices.
Now, in order to design
for so many devices,
it helps to have a vocabulary
to help categorize them.
At Google, we use
this design framework
called the multimodal spectrum.
It helps us categorize devices
based on their interaction
types.
So on one end, you have
voice-only devices,
like the Google Home and
other smart displays,
that you have to
hear or talk to.
On the other end, you
have visual-only devices,
like a phone or a
Chromebook, that's
on mute, and most watches.
So you have to look at
these devices or touch them.
And in the middle, you have
what we call multimodal devices
in that they're a mix of both.
Cars and smart displays that
rely primarily on voice,
but have optional visuals, are
known as voice-forward devices.
Phones and Chromebooks
with audio on,
which can use a mix of
both voice and visuals,
are known as intermodal devices.
So now, we have a vocabulary
for categorizing these devices.
But before we can start
designing for them,
it helps to understand the
strengths and weaknesses
of each of these modalities.
Let's talk about voice first.
Voice is great
for natural input.
We've been using
it for millennia.
Whether you're a kid,
a senior, or someone
who's not tech savvy, it's
still really intuitive.
It's great for hands-free,
far-field use cases,
like setting a timer in the
kitchen while you're cooking.
And it helps reduce
task navigation.
So for example, if
you were out on a run,
you could ask your favorite
Google action that's
about fitness and ask
it about your workouts
instead of having to
pull out your phone,
navigate to that app, and
search for that answer.
Similarly, you could
ask the Google Assistant
to play the next
song without having
to mess with any controls.
So voice has a lot of benefits.
It's great.
But it does have
some limitations.
And that's where
visuals come in.
Think about the last
time you were at a cafe.
You probably walked past all the
pastries, looked at the menu,
and made eye contact
with the cashier.
Think about how difficult
that interaction would be
if it was just through voice.
Have a listen at what
the menu would sound like
if it was through voice alone.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Espresso, latte, vanilla
latte, cappuccino, mocha,
Americano, flat white, hot
chocolate, black coffee,
and tea.
[END PLAYBACK]
SABA ZAIDI: That feels
pretty overwhelming, right?
It's like watching
all the options go by
and catching the right one.
It's like looking at a ticker.
Voice is ephemeral and linear.
And that makes it very difficult
to hold a lot of information
in your head.
By contrast, the
menu is a lot easier
to scan if it looks like this.
And you can imagine
that the problem
gets compounded if you also had
to compare prices in calories.
So visuals are great for
scanning and comparing.
We also use them a lot to
reference objects in the world.
So I can look at all the baked
goods and then point to the one
that I want.
Instead of, for example,
having to hear or say out
loud something like, that small,
sugar cookie with a chocolate
drizzle.
So voice and visuals
both have their benefits.
And it often is
useful to use both.
So in this example, we usually
prefer to look at the menu
but then talk to the cashier
in order to check out and pay.
Similar benefits to using
both voice and visuals
exist in the real world as
well or in the digital world
as well.
And that's what makes
multimodal devices, like phones
and smart displays, such
a unique opportunity.
By leveraging the best of
both voice and visuals,
they're able to provide
really rich interactions.
But how do we design
for them along
with designing for speakers?
One thing to keep
in mind, again,
is to start with a
human conversation.
You might have an app already,
but avoid the temptation
to duplicate it.
Instead, try to observe
a relevant conversation
in the real world or role
play it with a colleague
and write down that dialogue.
You'll realize that not
everything that's in your app
does well as conversation
or vice versa.
Instead, think of your
action as a companion
to your app that's faster
in certain use cases.
I won't go into detail into
how to write good dialogue
or create persona,
but I highly recommend
you check out our brand
new conversation design
website at that link there.
It goes into great detail
into how to get started.
So we've learned that we need
to create spoken dialogue
and then add visuals to it.
So let's take a look at an
example of how to do that
and how that helps us scale.
So if you haven't
already, I'd encourage
you to check out
the Google I/O 2018
action that helps you learn
more about this event.
We started by writing
a spoken dialogue
as if it was for a voice-only
device, like a Google Home.
And it includes
terms like this one.
So a user can say,
browse sessions.
And we respond with
a spoken response
like, here are some
of the topics left
for today and so on.
Now, in order to take this
dialogue and scale it,
we need to take
every turn like this
and think about all the
ways we can incorporate
visual components to it.
So this would include, for
example, display prompts,
cards, and suggestion chips.
In our example, we can
accompany that spoken prompt
with a display prompt
like, "Which topic are you
interested in?"
This helps carry the written
conversation on a screen.
We can add a list of
sessions as a card.
A user could tap on
that, for example.
And we could have a suggestion
chip like, "None of these."
And this helps the user know
how to pivot or follow up
a conversation.
Once we've constructed our
response to have spoken
and visual elements, we
can then map that response
to the multimodal
spectrum from earlier.
So depending on
whether the device
has visual or
audio capabilities,
or have important voices, we
can choose the right components.
So you already saw
what our response would
look like on a Google Home.
We would simply have
the spoken prompt.
Let's take a look
at what the response
would look like across
some of the other devices.
A smart display is a
voice-forward device.
So we still need to show
all the spoken prompt
and make it carry the
whole conversation.
We don't really need a display
prompt anymore, especially
if we're going to
have better visuals
like the list and the chips.
A phone, on the other
hand, is intermodal device.
And we need to
have both the voice
and the visuals carry
the conversation.
In this case, you might
notice that we shortened
the spoken prompt because we
can direct the user to look
at the screen for more details.
And Ulas will talk more
about how you can do that.
And of course, the rest
of the visual components
are there as well.
And finally, if your
phone was on silent,
we would simply ignore
the spoken prompt,
and the visual components
are able to carry
the complete conversation.
So now, we learned that in
order to scale our dialogue,
we need to write spoken prompts
and then add visuals to them.
And that helps us
map across devices.
But how do we know what
kinds of visuals to add?
I'd like to leave you
with five tips for how
you can incorporate
visuals into your dialogue.
For that, let's
take this made up
Assistant action called
the National Anthem
Player on a smart display.
As the name suggests, a
user can ask for a country,
and it will come back
with the national anthem
for that country.
When you invoke this action,
it gives you a welcome message
that sounds like this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Welcome to National
Anthem Player.
I can play the national anthems
from 20 different countries,
including United States,
Canada, and the United Kingdom.
Which would you like to hear?
[END PLAYBACK]
SABA ZAIDI: So as you
can see, the device
is currently writing
on the screen
what it's saying out loud.
And this is really a missed
opportunity, especially
given that by now, we've
learned that visuals
have some strength over voice,
and that smart displays are
great for showing rich,
immersive visuals.
So tip number one is to consider
cards rather than just display
prompts.
In this case, we've swapped
out the words for a carousel.
Users can quickly
browse through the list
and select the country
that they want.
You'll notice this is
similar to the menu example
we looked at in the cafe, where
visuals are helping someone
scan and compare options.
Additionally, things like
maps, charts, and images
are also great on
visual devices,
because they are difficult
to describe through voice,
similar to the cookie.
Second, consider varying your
spoken and your display prompt.
This is particularly useful for
devices that are intermodal,
that might have a display
prompt next to a card.
And some of that information
might be redundant.
So in this case,
we're stripping out
the examples for the
countries in the display
prompt because the card already
shows a lot of examples.
Third, consider visuals
for suggestions.
Here, we know that the
user is a repeat user.
So we're reordering the list
so that their most frequently
visited countries show up first.
We're also using suggestion
chips to allude to the user
how they can follow up
or pivot a conversation.
This kind of discovery can be
quite difficult through voice
alone.
Next, you can use visuals to
increase your brand expression.
We used to allow you to change
your voice and choose a logo,
but now we're also
going to be allowing
you to choose a font and
the background image.
And Ulas will talk more
about how you can do that.
As you can see
here, the experience
looks a lot more
custom and immersive.
And lastly, visual devices
are great for carrying
conversations that started
on a voice-only device.
So for example, if I use
this national anthem action
on a Google Home, and I
wanted to see the lyrics,
the action can send a
notification after a few steps
to my phone.
And I can take out my
phone and read them there.
So hopefully those
five tips will help you
in incorporating more
visuals into your dialogue.
Let's summarize what
we've learned so far
on how to design actions
for the Assistant.
First, users interact
with the Google Assistant
in a variety of different
ways and contexts.
So this could include
at home or on the go,
up close, at a distance, or
through voice or visuals.
In order to design across
so many modalities,
it helps to keep in mind
the multimodal spectrum
and think of your responses
as having visual components as
well as spoken components.
And lastly, learn and
leverage the strengths of each
of these modalities.
We learned, for
example, that visuals
are great at scanning, brand
expression, and discovery.
So instead of just
showing on the screen what
you're saying out loud,
try to use cards instead.
All right.
Now, I'm going to hand
it over to my colleague,
Ulas, who's going
to talk about how
you can develop these actions.
ULAS KIRAZCI: Thank you, Saba.
[APPLAUSE]
ULAS KIRAZCI: Hi.
So we said that the Assistant
runs on many types of devices.
And in the future, it
will run on many others.
Luckily, we make it easy for you
to build your action in a way
that it will run well on
all of these devices today,
as well as devices
in the future.
So let's go through an example.
To walk you through
this, I'm going
to use a test action I
created called California Surf
Report that gives wave height
and weather information
and beaches in
California for surfers.
So currently, I only have spoken
responses, no visuals yet.
So let's see what this sounds
like on a voice-only device
like the Google Home.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- --looks fair
for most of today.
Waves will be from two to
three feet in the morning,
to three to four feet
in the afternoon.
Expect waist-high swell in the
morning with northwest winds.
Shoulder-high surf in the
afternoon with southwest winds.
[END PLAYBACK]
ULAS KIRAZCI: OK, great.
Pretty informative.
So now, let's take
a look at what
this sounds like and looks
like on a voice-forward device,
like a smart display.
Switch to demo, please.
OK, Google.
Talk to California Surf Report.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
Let's get the test version
of California Surf Report.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Welcome
to California Surf Report.
ULAS KIRAZCI: Tell me the
surf report for Santa Cruz.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Surf
in Santa Cruz Beach
looks fair for most of today.
Waves will be from two to
three feet in the morning,
to three to four feet
in the afternoon.
ULAS KIRAZCI: OK.
I cut it short because I
think we all get the idea.
So as you can see,
spoken responses
are a good way to get
started and working well
on many devices.
But when we have a screen,
we can make it a lot better.
So let's see how.
One of the best visuals we can
add and the easiest ones to add
is a BasicCard.
And here's an example
from the Node.js client
library of how to add a
BasicCard to your responses.
So we start with a
spoken prompt as usual
and the second statement
of ask as a BasicCard.
A BasicCard can have a
title, subtitle, body text,
and optional image.
So let's see what this looks
like on our smart display
again.
Let's switch to
the demo, please.
OK, Google.
Show me the surf
report for Santa Cruz.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Surf
in Santa Cruz Beach
looks fair for most of today.
Waves will be from two to
three feet in the morning,
to three to four feet
in the afternoon.
Expect waist-high swell in the
morning with northwest winds,
shoulder-high surf in the
afternoon with southwest winds.
ULAS KIRAZCI: OK, great.
Now, it looks much better.
We have a nice visual for it
rather than huge lines of text.
And here are some other
kinds of cards you can use.
There's a carousel
on this card that
allows you to display
a set of things
that the user can choose from.
There's also a newly
introduced table card.
Another great way to add
visuals to your action
is to use suggestion chips.
Suggestion chips allow
the user to understand
what they can do in this
turn in the conversation.
And also, they
simplify user input.
You can learn more about
responses at the link.
And by the way, all of
this, like I promised,
works equally well on
an intermodal device,
like a phone.
As you can see,
we have formatted
the font sizes and the layout to
fit the intermodal form factor.
OK, great.
So next, maybe
what we want to do
is shorten the
spoken response a bit
because it's a bit repetitive
with the information that's
already on the card.
Users can just look at
the display for these.
So how do we do this?
We have a feature in the
API called capabilities.
So instead of thinking,
if Google Home,
do this, else if
smart display do that,
think about what capabilities
the surface that the user is
interacting with you on have.
Does it have a screen?
Can it output audio?
The capabilities of the
device are reported to you
in every webhook
call, so you get
to know what this is on
every conversation turn.
And here's a sample list of
capabilities that we support.
And you can learn
more at the link.
So in our use case,
what we're looking for
is the screen output capability.
This indicates that the
user device has a screen.
So we can show them a card.
Oh, and by the way, if you
don't want your responses
to differentiate between
ones with displays and ones
that are voice only, you
can always add a card,
and we'll just trip it
out for you silently.
So this makes it easy
for you to build if you
don't want to differentiate.
And here's, again, the
Node.js client library
snippet that shows
how to use this.
So in the first if
statement, we determined
that the user's device
does not have a screen.
So we have the full content
in the spoken response.
In the else clause, we know
that there is a screen.
So we shorten the
spoken response
and end it with a phrase
like, "Here's the report"
to lead the user to the screen.
And then we append the
BasicCard to the response.
So let's see how this looks
like on our smart display now.
Switch to demo, please.
OK, Google.
Show me the shortened surf
report for Santa Cruz.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Surf
in Santa Cruz Beach
looks fair for most of
today, with two to three foot
waves in the morning
and three to four foot
waves in the afternoon.
Here's the report.
ULAS KIRAZCI: So that
sounds a lot more concise
and user friendly.
Another way you can
use capabilities
is to require that
your action only
run on devices that
have the capability.
This is what we call
static capabilities.
And you can configure
these through the Actions
on Google console,
as you can see here.
But only use this if your
action absolutely makes no sense
without that capability.
So for example, the National
Anthem Player action
that Saba talked about would
not make sense on a device
without audio.
So this would be a
good place to use that.
However, for the
surf report app,
it equally works well on
voice-only and display-only
devices.
So it wouldn't be a
good place to use this.
You can configure all this using
the Actions on developer Google
console.
Another high quality and easy
way to target multiple surfaces
is to use Google
libraries we call helpers.
So I've been asking California
Surf Report the surf
report with the beach name.
But if I don't say the
beach name, I get a prompt,
"Which beach?"
Now, this doesn't tell
me what I can say.
It doesn't tell me which beaches
this action actually supports.
So we can fix that with a
helper called askWithCarousel.
What askWithCarousel does
is it presents the user
with a list of
options to pick from
and associate visuals
with each item.
In addition, when the
user utters the query
to select an item, Google
does the matching of the query
to the item.
So we can deal with
variations in how
people pick things much better.
So let's make our
prompt better with
the askWithCarousel helper.
And again, the Node.js
library snippet here.
We start with the spoken
response with the prompt.
And we add a carousel to it.
And the carousel is
made up of items.
And each item has
a list of phrases
that you think the user
might say to match this item
and visuals associated
with each item
so the user can understand
what they're about to tap on.
So let's switch to the demo
and see what this looks like.
OK, Google.
Show me the surf report.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Which beach do
you want to see the report for?
ULAS KIRAZCI: OK, so
this is the example
where I'm a little
confused as a user.
OK, Google.
Show me the beach carousel.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Which beach
would you like to know about?
ULAS KIRAZCI: OK, great.
Now it's much easier
for me to understand
what the possible options
are, and even tap on one
if I want to go with that.
And we always continuously
improve the experience
with these helpers.
So this is one of the
advantages of helpers,
is that we continue to
modify them to optimize them
for surfaces.
Now, since we launched
the current API last year,
we've since come up
with smart displays.
As you noticed on
smart displays,
each conversation turn
takes up the entire screen.
So given this fact, maybe we can
make our visuals more branded
and give them a
little bit more flair.
So we're introducing
styling options this year.
So here's how it works.
Let's switch to
the demo, please.
So here is a new
tab in the Actions
on Google console called
theme customization.
You can modify the background
color, primary color--
so that's like the font
color of the text--
and the typography, and
even set a background image.
So let's try a few things here.
Let's say we want to
make this cursive.
Let's add a background image.
OK, so this is the landscape
aspect ratio image.
And then we want to add
a portrait image as well.
All right, all set.
Now, all we have to do is save.
And then we click
Test right here
to update our test version.
All right, now, let's see what
this looks like on the demo.
OK, Google.
Show me the surf
report for Santa Cruz.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Surf
in Santa Cruz Beach
looks fair for most of
today, with two to three foot
waves in the morning
and three to four foot
waves in the afternoon.
Here's the report.
ULAS KIRAZCI: I think now
that looks really beautiful.
Smart displays are coming
out later this year.
However, you can start
building your action
against these visuals today,
using the updated simulator.
So we've added a new simulator
device type for smart displays,
as you can see here.
And we've also
added a display tab,
which shows you the
full-screen version of what you
would get on a smart display.
You can also use
this with a phone.
And on the left
side as usual, you
have the spoken responses,
as well as an input box
where you can put user queries.
One last thing, we said that
Assistant is in many places.
So if the user's
interacting with your action
using a voice-only
device, maybe they also
have a device that has a display
on it, for example, a phone.
So what if, in your current
turn in the conversation,
you really want to have your
response display something?
So for example, in the
surf report action,
the user might ask us
for the full report.
And we want to return the hour
by hour wave height graph.
So how do we do that?
There's a feature
in the API called
multi-surface conversations.
And here's how it works.
In each API call
to your webhook,
we report not only
the capabilities
of the device that the
user's currently using,
but the union of the
capabilities of all the devices
the user owns.
So in this example, what you
see is that the current user
device only has a voice output
capability and has no screen.
But in available surfaces,
we can see the screen output
capability.
So the user seems to
have another device
with a screen on it.
So how do we use this?
Again, in the client
library we have a function
to help you to inspect if the
user has a certain capability
among their devices.
Now, we determine
that the user has
a device with this capability.
How do we transfer the
user to the other device?
We have a function, ask for
new surface, that does this.
And you can give it
a notification that
will appear on
the target device,
in addition to the
list of capabilities
you require for continuing
your conversation.
I'm not going to demo this,
but here's what it looks like.
So let's say the user said,
show me the full report.
And they're talking to
you on a Google Home.
So you would call the
ask new surface function
that I showed you earlier.
And we ask the user permission
to send the conversation over
to the user's phone.
And if the user
accepts, then there's
a notification sent
to the new device.
The conversation ends
on the current device.
And when the user
taps the notification,
then they resume
the conversation
from where you left
off, like this.
Note that this is not
just for single responses.
This works equally
well when you want
to continue the conversation.
So we bring the full context
over so you can continue
from where you left off.
So to sum up, we've built a
lot of features in the API
for you to add visuals
to your responses.
So please use them.
And we make it such that
we take your responses
and optimize them as best
as possible to all these
surfaces, and
surfaces in the future
without extra work from you.
And if you wanted to
customize your responses,
always think of capabilities
and not individual device types.
This way, we can run your
action on new devices
without any extra work from you.
SABA ZAIDI: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So I'd just like to end
with an invitation for you.
Next time you order
coffee at a cafe
or do a presentation
like this one,
start to notice all the
different modes of interactions
you use every day.
And let the richness of
those human conversations
inspire how you design
actions for your users.
And help us evolve what it
means to have conversations
with technology.
Here's some links to
resources we mentioned
and how to give feedback.
So also come just talk to us.
We'll be with our team
at the Assistant office
hours and Sandboxes, ready
to answer your questions
and showing off
some of the devices.
So thank you and good luck.
ULAS KIRAZCI: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]